In this lesson, we'll focused on getting
your brain engaged in the planning portion of creating
a Power BI data model in anticipation of developing your data model and reports.
My big takeaway for you is yes to unicorns,
yes to UniBrowse, no to Uni-tables.
In this lesson, we learned about the core components of a data model structure.
First, we talked about the wrong way to model your data with Uni-tables.
This is where we mash everything together and create
one giant very inefficient table, no Bueno.
Then we talked about the main components of a data model.
In particular, fact tables,
dimension tables, keys, and relationships between our tables.
We saw that one of the key takeaways in this lesson is that
by separating our data into fact tables and dimension tables,
then using relationships to connect them,
we can create much more efficient and useful data models.
Planning the tables and relationships in your data model is critical.
We learned that one of the ways that we can do this is with
a simple sketch of a data model before we start building anything,
which becomes our roadmap.
We considered at a high level,
how we can restructure source data,
logically shifting or transforming datasets to
meet needs of a data model and the resulting report,
including options to merge one source
of data with another or rework the columns and rows represented.
We used the VertiPaq Analyzer in DAX Studio to
make some of these key best-practices complete,
including that deleting one fact table column can
make significantly more impact than 13 dimension columns individually.
Now that we've gotten some practice thinking through
some basic data models and planning them out,
we're ready to get some hands-on practice with getting data in Power BI, Power Query.